and I hope I'm preaching to the  converted but if there's a single person  in this room who doesn't know what I'm  about to say them it's worth repeating  and that is we are not bullshitting you  this is not yoga this is not an NLP not  to not suspect this is real it is so  real that you can take the most hardened  rational reductionist [ __ ] drop them  in to that environment and he will meet  his maker  it dissolves you into a confrontation  with authentic being and this is what we  are starving for this is how we've  gotten into the messes and mess that  we're in take seriously the techniques  of shamanism study the plan make real  choices and then don't Dibble the dose  once you've done your homework  you